en medio de un rápido aumento de nuevas
infecciones cientos de peruanos se
tomaron las calles de lima este jueves
para protestar contra las nuevas medidas
restrictivas anunciadas por el gobierno
el presidente interino francisco sagasti
anunció el martes el cierre total de la
capital y de otras 9 regiones a partir
del próximo lunes para evitar un
desborde del sistema sanitario medidas
rechazadas por un amplio sector de la
ciudadanía que teme un impacto demasiado
profundo para la economía no enviaremos
más monta miento
otros denuncian una conspiración
internacional para afectar al país
el gobierno provenientes a directivas
internacionales que se imponen a nivel
mundial es de suprimir la libertad
de los propósitos que tienen estás
cuarentenas es quebrar la economía no
solamente de este país sino de todos los
países para hacer un reseteo mundial
pero con más de 40 mil muertes es uno de
los países más golpeados de la región y
ahora hace frente a una nueva oleada de
contagios que tiene a los sistemas
hospitalarios al límite pero el límite
está también la economía que cayó un
11.6 por ciento en 2020 y se espera que
la vacunación no empiece hasta febrero